one of the things i read was that he was
the worst guitar teacher you said to him
i don't know how old you were but you
were very young when you want to learn
how to play guitar
and you said to your father dada you
know i want to learn how to play guitar
he said within two seconds he's playing
like eddie van halen
it's you know i'll i'll ask him how to
play something
and then he just proceeds to be eddie
van halen and
that's a very uh tough bar to reach as a
beginner so it's like
oh okay you know he's like we'll do this
and it's like [ __ ] you
you're eddie van gaal how the hell do i
do that what's in that room
i see a bunch of guitars i brought this
one out for you because i thought you
you might like it
this is this is the first guitar of my
dad's
that he gave me um and a lot of van
halen fans will
will know that in the panama video he he
plays
he has he has two kramer guitars this is
a kramer one that has
1984 written at the bottom and one has
5150 this was the backup to the 5150.
uh the 5150 model was the one he plays
in the panama video and i think he plays
it in the uh
in live without a net um and for my
birthday for christmas
when i was really young he gave he like
legally
gave it nothing i was gonna steal it but
like like he he gave it to me
you know as a gift um and this was the
first thing he gave me
yeah you know i have a wolfgang guitar
that your father signed to me i have it
hanging in my house
man i cherish that i'm you know he wrote
he wrote he wrote some great things on
it
howard i don't care what people
say about you really in parentheses or
me
all the best eddie van halen that was
really cool
to see the guitar i actually i hadn't
seen this until um i opened the case
but he gave me a card with it and he was
really proud of the
of the joke it's a playboy card but when
he said it
he was like play boy you know
boy um and uh he was
like see this is that's what he wrote he
was really proud of like the 3d effect
he did
merry christmas you know gave me a
playboy card
yeah and i it was really emotional i i
completely forgot about it until i
opened the case
and saw it it's been years since i saw
this but he i just remember him saying
play boy